[Music]
so I'm Scott ransom I'm at the National
Radio Astronomy Observatory in
Charlottesville Virginia and also at the
universe of Regina and I have to admit I
have a problem my problem is that I'm
obsessed with pulsars and as many of my
colleagues here know that is
definitively true and I'll tell you
during this talk hopefully why that is
why I'm obsessed with them
and unlike Jay I have no problem with
using the a word about these objects
these are freaking awesome hopefully
you'll get you'll get that from my talk
so the way I'm gonna start this out is
with a hero of mine and that's Jocelyn
Bell and hopefully many of you in the
audience know that name if you don't I
implore you later tonight or sometime
soon to go on the internet and look up
her story she is the discoverer of
pulsars this is a picture for of her
when she was a graduate student back in
1967 in Cambridge and her adviser and
her and several other people built this
radio telescope and yes that's not a
fence behind her that's a radio
telescope because if you observe radio
waves a long enough radio wavelengths
you can build them out of regular wires
and fence posts effectively so this
whole thing in the background here is
all a radio telescope and it was
constructed so that they could measure
quasars which had recently been
discovered they were gonna monitor how
bright these quasars were as a function
of time that they were looking at the
variability of these quasars and so what
the way this telescope worked is the
radio signals would be output through
with an old-school pen style chart
recorder so the intensity of the radio
waves come coming into the telescope as
the earth rotated would be written as
little Wiggles on this pen chart
recorder and what Jocelyn's job was as a
graduate student was every day she would
take the tens of
leaders of pen chart recordings that had
been recorded and she would try to
figure out where are the quasars as they
rotated over how bright were they how
big the Wiggles were and to look and to
try to figure out what are the
Astrophysical sources that the quasars
and remove from them the huge number of
terrestrial interfering sources that she
saw because even our modern society even
back in 1967 we produce a whole lot of
radio interference
sparkplugs from cars sparking electric
fences you name it it can cause a whole
bunch of extra wiggles and the data and
what she did very very carefully was
found a very strange and anomalous
signal which she thought was
Astrophysical and the great thing about
predicting that something's asked your
physical she was able to say on this
certain night it should be visible at
this time and lo and behold when she and
her adviser went back at exactly that
time they saw little blips on the chart
recorder about once per second with
clock-like regularity and that was the
astonishing thing because quasars were
thought they would see variability on
hours maybe certainly on days weeks and
months time scales but no one expected
to see radio signals varying once per
second that was astonishing and it
turned out that they had made one of the
biggest discoveries in astrophysics or
even physics of the last century so what
did they find they found these guys this
is a cartoon version of a radio pulsar
it's a it's a type of spinning star I'll
talk about it in more in more detail as
it rotates it's like a lighthouse
there's a beam of radiation and if it as
a sweeps past we see a pulse of radio
waves in this case we've also taken the
radio intensity and put it into a
speaker so you can hear a blip of that
of the sound as well so where do these
things come from what types of objects
are these actually well we've heard
about the way that stars are effectively
devices for transforming hydrogen into
heavier elements that's what they do via
the process of fusion and most of the
stars in our galaxy are these little
puny guys here's our Sun but as you go
to bigger bigger mass stars such as
these these
big guys here they are gonna eventually
at the end of their lifetime when they
fuse all their hydrogen they'll explode
as supernovae and large talked about
that beautifully earlier in the day the
core of those stars though are
transformed during this process that's
what happens in a supernova it's the
transformation of the core of a star
into what's going to be effectively a
pulsar and what you get right away at
least are these and you've even seen a
picture of the Crab Nebula earlier as
well here's the ejecta from the
supernova but what lars didn't mention
earlier is that almost all the glow that
you see in this image and this image
shows wavelengths clear from radio waves
clear up to x-rays all of that energy
all of that glow is coming from this
central object at the very center here
that is a pulsar that pulsar is
energizing that nebula causing it to
glow so these are really amazing objects
and what what that is what that core
transformed into is a neutron star so
what are these neutron stars well
they're incredibly exotic objects some
of the most exotic objects in the
universe period and one of the things
you've heard earlier is that black holes
are very exotic but they're simple they
really only have masked or the curvature
of space and time these actually have a
surface they have magnetic fields they
have a bunch of interesting properties
that we can measure so for one these
have the masses of everything in our
solar system but all at the size of a
city that means they're extraordinarily
dense they're the same density or even
denser by a factor of a few than atomic
nuclei so if you think about it you have
a giant nucleus made almost exclusively
of neutrons that's the size of a city
that's extraordinary and that causes a
lot of other special things you have a
tremendous density there's an incredible
high surface temperature these are about
a million degrees Kelvin so they emit in
the x-rays that density causes an
incredibly strong gravitational field
Lewis talked about this earlier when he
talked about dropping the clicker and
how that would release the energy of a
nuclear bomb it's a billion times
stronger gravity than the surface of the
earth that's extraordinary that's a big
number 100 billion times even more
mind-boggling to me and I study these
all the time is that these can rotate up
to seven
100 or more times per second that's
faster than a kitchen blender rotates
that's faster than a racecar engine
rotates and yet these are the size of a
city and these objects that spin very
very rapid these are the ones that I
concentrate my research on the so called
millisecond pulsars the blue of this in
the background all this blue these blue
curves these are met at the magnetic
field lines and as you rotate that
magnetic field which is incredibly
strong it can be billions trillions or
even quadrillions of times stronger than
the Earth's magnetic field that causes
these radiation beams that are coming
out of the poles here these radiation
beams that sweep like a lighthouse and
those are what we actually measure
typically it's in the radio waves but
you can also see x-rays and gamma rays
as well and the amazing thing is that
all this energy that's coming off these
objects is purely coming from the spin
of the object from the rotation and that
can be as much energy as 10,000 times
the amount of output of the Sun purely
from rotation these are giant fly wheels
in space and for the millisecond pulses
especially they're basically perfect
clocks and what I like to do is use
these clocks to do extra physics use
them as tools to do cool physics and we
do that by a process known as pulsar
timing and the pulsar timing the way it
works is that blue sentence at the top
of the salt slide we unambiguously
account for every single rotation of the
Pulsar over timescales of years and if
the Pulsar is rotating hundreds of times
per second like a millisecond pulsar
does and the earth is moving around the
Sun and the Pulsar is moving across the
sky very slowly and the Pulsar is moving
in orbit around another star you have to
do a whole bunch of things to count
pulses very very regularly and our data
kind of looks like this we see
individual pulses and you can hear when
those pulses are arriving so what we're
gonna do now to try to explain a little
bit how this works is we're gonna do a
little bit of an audience participation
exercise so it sounds really amazing how
you might model how these pulses are
gonna arrive especially if we can't
observe a pulsar all the time for
instance I go to a telescope when I
observe today but I don't observe for
the next week or two how do I know how
pulses are coming during that week or
two when I'm not observing well the way
we do it just like Bart was talking
about last time it's the way science
works we have a model that we build to
explain our observations that model lets
us then predict what's happening in the
future which we can then check when we
go back and observe again so what we're
gonna do with this with this
soundbite here I'm gonna have you we're
gonna play that pulsar sound I want you
to get the rhythm of the Pulsar in your
mind don't clap or anything because
you'll screw it up for everyone else but
keep it in your mind think of that
pulsar going and then the pulse is gonna
go away that's like you going away from
the observatory you're going to go
you're going to sleep for the night or
going on vacation or whatever and then
it'll come back again and what I want
you to tell me first off is two things
how many pulses did you miss
how many pulses were there there went
when the pulse when you weren't hearing
it and second how close were you keeping
time with your mind when the pulse comes
back were you right on the beat or were
you a little bit off so you can go ed
and play the sound
how close were you were you right on how
many pulses were missed I heard a whole
bunch of answers the correct answer was
10 there were 10 missing pulses but
that's why I'm at a pulsar astronomer
and you're not anyways so uh but the
amazing thing is though with when you do
this model incorrectly with high
precision pulsars and computers you can
get incredibly precise results and let
me show you an example of that for
millisecond pulsars these can be some of
the most precise clocks that we know
about anywhere as good or even better
than some atomic clocks so what I mean
by that well this particular pulsar is
one of the best measured pulsars that we
know of it's a famous millisecond pulsar
I don't worry about its number but at
3:05 on five minutes off in five minutes
this pulsar will have a spin period of
exactly four point five seven zero one
three six five two two nine etc
milliseconds but I'm an observer and a
scientist we need error bars on our
measurements when I put an error bar on
the measurement this is the error bar
two in that last digit these are some of
the most precise measurements in all of
physics and if we can track that that
that period incredibly precisely we can
do really cool things with it like I
said the pulsar's are slowing down
because they're giving off energy that
means that numbers changing like the
odometer on a car it's slowing down that
numbers getting bigger so how much is it
changing well that very last digit this
one right here changes by about one
every two minutes that's just like an
odometer and if you think about what
that means that means that this digit
right there
it takes 4000 years for that digit to
change so those first six digits are
effectively constant for thousands and
thousands of years that's why we can use
these things as perfect clocks to do
physics so when in my last couple
minutes I'm going to just give you this
flavor of the type of physics that we
can do with these objects
you've heard about how Einstein's theory
of general relativity is a warping of
space and time well if we have a pulsar
that's in an orbit with another star
that warped space-time means that the
orbits are not a ellipses as Newton and
Kepler would have predicted they're
close to ellipses but not precisely and
that means the orbits change with time
we're using pulsars with this highly
precise clock we can measure exactly how
these orbits change with time and that
lets us test general relativity and in
fact this is exactly what Russell Hulse
and Joe Taylor did that that was a vicky
Cassidy's thesis adviser Joe Taylor they
won the Nobel Prize for making exactly
that measurement and showing that the
orbit was shrinking exactly as predicted
by general relativity because there was
get they were giving off gravitational
waves and I should mention that's the
second Nobel Prize that pulsars have won
the first Nobel Prize was for the
initial discovery of pulsars by who do
you think not Jocelyn Bell Jocelyn
Bell's advisor which is a whole nother
story but these are some of the two
types of things we can do with general
relativity we can measure the masses we
can determine the properties of these
pulsars to incredible precision and even
do nuclear physics to tell us what's
going on at the Centers of these objects
and then my very last slide is my very
long term project that's going on that
I'm part of and Vickie is as well it's
called nano grav and with this project
we're trying to directly detect
gravitational waves that are coming from
supermassive black holes that are
starting to merge when two galaxies have
merged because these supermassive black
holes are at the center of the Centers
of galaxies and they make very long
period gravitational waves that are like
years long and the earth then kind of is
riding on this sea of gravitational
waves and the measurement is actually
quite simple if there's pulsar spread
all over the sky and let's say you guys
are all pulsars and I am the earth if
gravitational waves makes makes me
jiggle the earth closer to you as
pulsars your pulses are all going to be
a little bit early the Pulsar the pulses
from the pulse was behind me are gonna
be a little bit late the pulses from the
Pulsar is on the side don't get changed
at all
when I do go back this way it
versus so over the timescale of years we
can measure directly just like LIGO has
the gravitational waves from these
supermassive black holes and we've been
working on this for over 10 years where
these are for very very long slopes low
gravitational waves and we think we're
very very near a detection this would
open up a second window into the
gravitational wave universe and allow us
to see something the the near the near
collisions of supermassive black hole
binaries that are almost impossible to
measure in any other way so I'll end
there and I hopefully you'll see why I'm
kind of obsessed with pulsars and why I
think they're freaking awesome Thanks
[Applause]